we are here at McLaren and I want to
thank you very taking the time to speak
with me so we're here and this also was
at Ian's headquarters yes so what does
that conversation go like when you're
like hi I really like this place can we
use it as the lair of supervillains they
were really open I mean I think that the
the whole team here at McLaren was like
excited that we were gonna use the cars
and like really sort of supportive of
getting us product and then the fact
that we wanted to shoot here and it was
an inspiration for the tech element I
think that we were trying to bring into
et on it was like we can't build
anything like this could you give us
access to this facility like this is
amazing and then they were really yeah
gracious to do it so you've come out
with three films in three years anatomic
blonde Deadpool 2 and now Hobbs and show
what has your life been like what kind
of work schedule do you have to crank
out not just like Indies but like major
tentpole blockbusters in that time it's
been a it's been an a tremendous amount
of work I mean you know those they all
have challenges in their own right you
know we're doing atomic blonde and the
budget is really really small and tight
and it was John wick sighs and so that
requires your attention 24/7 to to
magnify the resources and then you have
these other two movies that are giant
brands to take care of and like that's
24/7 and so I have not really stopped
working him and we were doing post on
Deadpool I was in the last sort of weeks
of editorial when I took the jobs on
Hobbs and Shaw and we were developing
the script with Chris Morgan while I was
testing Deadpool 2 so it's been non-stop
and it's been films that kind of
all-consuming so you're like seven days
a week as a director but it's high-class
problems man I love making movies so
it's all good like I'm not I don't I'm
ready to make another one
this is this is your first pg-13 film
yeah I was wondering did that offer any
new challenges or it was there anything
kind of exciting about that to say there
are certain things we can't do but with
this pg-13 framework it allows me to
kind of create two creative options I
didn't have otherwise yeah I think any
time you put restrictions on yourself it
forces creativity you know like again
like I said the budget of atomic blonde
was the ex so we were got creative and
that's how we came up with the the long
sort of one or piece and like you know
how do we amplify the the production
value here and do something provocative
I think pg-13 is just a different box
and it allows you to reach another
audience and it allowed us to take the
tone in a different place and have fun
with that so I was full-on to embrace
pg-13 I guess it gets a little hard with
the fighting sometimes because you
you're so used to seeing the things that
you want and they're like take that down
a notch and like really that was cool
but it's okay you'll see it on the
blu-ray are there any sort of you know
you've done so many different kinds of
action scenes does it sort of become a
way of wanting to challenge yourself and
say we haven't done this before I
haven't done this before but you don't
want to repeat yourself like there's so
there's no like you know one or this
uncut one or in Hobbes and Shaw right
but is there anything like I really want
to attempt this kind of set piece in
this film there what there wasn't I
think every movie speaks to you
obviously in a different way and you can
see the sort of I've tried to tailor the
action to service the story so the one
or in atomic blonde was really servicing
this character at that moment in time
and the story of like we had these fun
set pieces with the hose and like some
other things and then when the stakes
got you know ultimate the real we rip
out the score and we're with Charlize
for you know 12 uncut minutes right here
the action is is servicing you in a
different way and like but as long as
you sort of a attack your design from
story and character and then it's gonna
work you know it's when people just do
spectacle spectacle that it kind of
feels empty right you don't know why you
know but you do know why yeah
when so the John wick franchise has gone
on to become this huge end with each one
is more successful is that something
you'd ever think about returning to to
co-direct with chat or trying to take it
on good question no I'll never say never
I'm such a huge fan of what we created
and that something would you know have
that long of legs and like reach that
many people and and again like very few
franchises you know start with no IP and
then go on to make more money make more
money make more money so I'll never say
never I don't know I mean it'd be
interesting I love John wick and I love
the world and I love Keanu and I love
Chad so it would be easy to do when it's
such a it's such a must be a pretty cool
success to sort of to have originated
that character and now you know you can
use a shorty like oh he got John wycked
and it's you know I'm gonna create this
sort of almost arc new archetype yeah
it's it's it's really cool and I'm very
proud of that whole thing in that yeah
we've created something that's so iconic
and that it's you know made it into the
lexicon and all these different ways
like it's cool it's pretty cool now
you're also attached to the division and
I have to ask you know so many video
game movies have run into problems and
I'm curious what do you think it is with
the division that's going to sort of get
over that hump that a lot of other
adaptations have run into well I think
that it's look when you look at the
adaptations of video game movies it's it
often becomes about like set pieces that
are you know all about the spectacle and
sort of it's about these set pieces that
aren't attached to real drama and real
characters I think like anything I have
to approach it from a characters that we
care about and let again like I just
spoke to the set pieces drive
development for the characters and
development for the plot the experience
that you have playing a video game you
immerse yourself in set pieces in it and
you have a visceral response you'll
never be able to recreate that on film
what you can recreate is like great
human characters good human stories and
then still have action but it resonates
with a character that you're attached to
for
the film and not are you experiencing
it's so it's hard but I think we can do
it I'm excited about it
awesome thank you so much for taking the
time to speak with me I really
appreciate it thank you